[Musique]
c'était vendredi
scénario se répétera demain résultat des
salles de classe comme celle-ci sont
vides
bon nombre de conseils scolaires devront
fermer leurs écoles ou encore se tourner
vers l'apprentissage en virtuel on peut
pas travailler de façon adéquate et
avoir des enfants qui font l'école
virtuelle
Omar burgand passera son lundi à la
maison avec ses deux enfants chaque
matin nous demande de ce que c'est une
journée de grève aujourd'hui ou non et
même nous qu'en tant que parents il y a
beaucoup d'incertitude ces deux enfants
fréquentent une école élémentaire qui se
tourne vers l'enseignement virtuel
jusqu'à nouvel ordre si la grève se
poursuit le fils de Mendy shell restera
lui aussi à la maison demain c'est
difficile de trouver comme une solution
pour tous les trois de travailler de la
maison c'est assez de bruit c'est
difficile pour lui de se concentrer
c'est un mâle pour un bien selon elle
puisque comme Omar burgant elle soutient
la cause des travailleurs nous nous
sommes rendus vendredi à la
manifestation pour participer mon fils a
eu de laid quand il était au primaire
des éducatrices qui lui est dans la
classe on peut pas garder les écoles
ouvertes au détriment des travailleurs
c'est les deux sont viennent ensemble
les conditions travaillent des gens qui
travaillent dans nos écoles c'est aussi
les conditions d'apprentissage des
élèves
c'est un véritable casse-tête pour bien
des parents et ça l'est tout autant pour
la Commission des relations de travail
de l'Ontario après trois jours
d'audience il doit rendre sa décision et
déterminer si le débrayage est illégal
une décision suivie de près partout au
pays selon cette expert
en sorte que ça dépasse vraiment les
limites de la province de l'Ontario
c'est au niveau climatique tout le
milieu syndical surveille cette
situation là le Syndicat canadien de la
fonction publique tiendra un point de
presse demain pour faire le point sur la
situation il sera accompagné de
dirigeants syndicaux nationaux et
provinciaux ici Rosalie Sinclair
Radio-Canada
Ottawa